former Miss USA Shanna Moakler calls out
Miss Colombia for calling herself Miss
Universe I have to apologize the first
runner-up is Colombia Miss Universe 2015
is Philippines yeah hard to keep
watching that cringe-worthy moment where
Steve Harvey crowned the wrong winner
even more awkward miss Colombia is still
basking in her short-lived reign posting
a photo of her crowning moment riding
forever your Miss Universe et caught up
with another beauty queen who says that
caption is quote really inappropriate
though Moakler sympathizes with Ariana
Gutierrez
embarrassing loss she says quote there
is only one winner in pageants I was
first runner-up and there is something
to be said about losing gracefully
meanwhile Miss Universe Pia wurtzbach is
forging ahead after the pageant drama
Pia shared her first selfie jetting off
to her new apartment in New York where
she will live during her year-long reign
she gushed in the caption
goodbye Vegas hello New York City this
is my first time seeing the Big Apple